you 37 weezy aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur ce toit way un jeu d'horreur et oui
je prenais un dramatique alors ça sert à
rien c'est parti à l'orge absolument
aucune idée est ce qu'on doit faire
peut-être probablement prendre ces
objets hop c'est quoi c'est une sorte de
sonar bon et cette feuille à atom et
c'est flou oscar bon flow putain peut
être mais le net trouvait au s'était
fait objectif principal à naviguer de
l'autre côté du detec
ok trouver une lampe trouvé une boîte à
outils et réguler la pression des valves
ok bah écoutez c'est parti j'aurais bien
mais qu'on trouve la lampe torche dans
la seconde là maintenant hop c'est quoi
ces bruits putain les mecs ça fait
carrément peur moi je cherche la lande
tort je tâche voit que dalle tap to view
cct doux c'est quoi ça ah c'est le truc
qu'on vient de ramasser ça permet de
voir ce cas là bas c'est ça qu'est ce
que c'est que ça alors dans mes choix
riad la lumière talent et diabète pour
lire les notes aa voilà les munitions et
les ressources sont limitées à utiliser
avec modération
très bientôt mais je suis tout sauf
rassurer ça dégage allez donc là bas y'a
rien là bas est rien on peut y aller si
la bayard rien à envier aux quais putain
o'toole view objective
non mais c'est bon je les ai déjà vus
600 fois bordeaux n'a fait que ça depuis
les buts cette vidéo vous allez arrêter
à la fin des parties ou aulaqi talent
alors il n'y a pas une flash lite pas
ici une belle et douce flash lite comme
on les aime ces brouilles et allez on
ouvre sa on ouvre à l'est voilà bonjour
y at il un grand méchant loup partout au
hasard ou probablement un méchant plus
méchante qu'un grand méchant loup
euh c'est quoi ce bordel tout ça ne me
dit rien qui vaille à je déteste cette
phase dans laquelle on ne sait pas à
quoi ressemble le méchant aussi pas en
réunion mec c'est moi ben c'est
clairement pas moi y avait du mental et
presse 1 to turn by turn off ça marche
pas on fouillait les fouilles au dip il
thank you aller j'y vais avec un grand
courage bien sûr oh là le mec un peu
monter on va prendre cette note des
quatre manquer ce qu'il y à là bas je me
penche de 2 cm qui ne sert à rien
apprendre cette feuille aux nains faut
que traduisent encore attendez je vais
juste essayer deux ans putain ya une
ombre c'est du fake puis sur cd ballet
des chiffons et à et assemblé ça fait
une ombre d'hommes comme ça bah voilà
bah finalement y'a rien et l'ombre elle
a disparu bas c'est parfait je suis sûr
que j'ai oublié ma lampe de poche
quelque part ici ah bon ah ça nous
arrange et à putte un autre de poche
est ce que c'est ça non ça c'est un
briquet bas c'est parti on y va attendre
folle et en bas ou alors fois les la
voile et en bas je pense à être des
armes ça doit être pas putain
prêté attention une vague qui à faire
nathan le briquet au phoque
le briquet pourquoi je peux pas à lui
mais putain briquet jérôme haas ger and
that are du gros des directs hockey
putain non mais c'est pas vrai ça à
grand âge peut ouvrir la porte ou pas ah
bah non ça marche plus et ben je
continue ma route dans l'obscurité
totale ces salons poche
oh oui comment je sors la lampe poche
après ce 2-cm hakim h mortels
pourquoi quand je la fusion 2 s'allume
cazals n'ont pas suffi regardez regardez
tourner en rond attendaient un problème
là au lieu d'aller en bas chercher une
lampe torche qui ne marche pas on va
bien tracée vers la balle toute manière
voilà c'est parti
asap le skimmer je sais pas pourquoi ça
marche pas quand je vais mais la lumière
s'est peut-être fait exprès de santec
coup y avait un mec j'ai horreur de ça
putain des menus qui courent dans les
nues couloir nu nu j'ai dit trop de fois
le mot nul mais c'est vrai quoi putain
c'est qu'armand aulas arrêté arrêté trop
de bruit à la seconde s'il vous plaît
gens peu plus haut on voit une table
avec une caisse de munitions dessus
annoncé la boîte à outils et oui il faut
se souvenir des objectifs d'axione allez
on prend le 20e briquets jetables
souillés collection de briquets quoi
attend une note
alors y'a marqué quoi dessus 12 dames
devant top ster alors google traduction
merci
ces évents delobel étage toujours ce
boucher si je dois ramper à travers eux
une fois de plus trois petits points
bon et ce qu'ils devaient dire un truc
ça donc faut passer par la salle de
stockage pour accéder aux escaliers qui
mènent au sommet du pont des pour
réparer les ventes putain soit trop
compliqué allons-y les enfants ça pue le
screamer audiovisuel et voire même
sensuelle aussi pas tactile plutôt
screamer tactile ah oui ok il ya une
bonne grosse fuite
on voit que dalle c'est simple vous
voyez rien je crois rien non plus ça
qu'est bon au moins on pourra pas se
rendre compte si on est on est dans la
terreur ah mon dieu
voici la boîte à outils faut maintenant
retourner dans les escaliers des dupont
dz q2 c'est une putain d'équations ce
jeu bon sens au wahoo à mais qu'est ce
qui se passe avec m'a arrêté avec mauss
krieber bizarre c'est par là on ira on
se sauve à mon aux putains bon on y va à
l'aveuglé bah ouais mais j'ai pas de
langue ça marche pas à n'en faut sauter
là dessus a affolé dans les ventilations
bonjour je ne vois rien puisqu'il a
absolument rien qui marche on peut pas
sortir notre briquet ou note torche
narva c'est plein de trucs on pèse
d'utiliser ces affreux ques comme tu te
donnes et du pas et je faisais manger
d'une oreillette et nul mais on voit
rien aussi peut-être ventilation oui oh
mon dieu mais qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est
top et du coup oh oui merci j'ai été si
tout pouvait prendre feu sorte à ce que
je vois bien tout ce qui m'entoure ce
serait parfait nous on est des projets
d'horreur voilà pgm on a fait de la
ligue on a fait de l'histoire sur des
jeux d'horreur on peut le dire voilà
donc où est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'une lampe torche ou la brique et m'a
bien sûr que nous on voit rien regarder
en dehors des chronos à l'habitat à bas
c'est bien d'un coup merci belle chute à
temps il s'est passé tout pas bien ici
quoi il ya des portes enfoncées alors à
j'ai entendu un bruit très peu agréables
à yannick ya vous attendez il ya un
putain monstre
wada lensois il a une trompette vraiment
extrêmement abusé en décibels soit tant
pis je vais me faire et je vais faire ce
qu'il faut faire
regardez tient un briquet tient des
piles une note tout ce qu'il faut et eu
besoin d'utiliser un jeu près sur ce
tome right one of this day is going to
blow les pressions sont vraiment trop
élevé un de ces jours ça va exploser je
me demande combien de temps cette vague
va réguler la pression le capitaine ne
veut rien entendre
ok c'est pas mon problème alors se passe
un truc c'est quoi c'est la tête d'un
mec mais attends mais il ya un mec
carrément glauque aux abords ou une note
mondiaux a été cachée comme ça dans un
recoin n était bien celle là aurait t il
faut s'accroupir pour passer au plat un
petit briquet qui sert à rien bien sûr
pierre vallet revendre à la fin c'est
sûr pas une note par terre là non il ya
des dossiers regarder cet homme à la
fraude est jolie là je ne l'avais pas vu
oh mon dieu au camer les mecs via un mec
fait peur enfin trouvé ce petit canapé
confortable avec cette petite table
basse est les gens dit qu'une serveuse
sur les présidentes là bas aussi nous
amener le petit déjeuner après la sieste
putain mais qui seront pas ou gauche il
est terrifiant ce jeu bordel personnes
se moquent aux quêtes et les dix mois
tout bon a fait pas semblant bois fait
des choses de pâques à moitié il te
plaît aux mondiaux la salle elle te
regarde personne me regardes et tu pars
de la télé à l'émulation tellement pas
répondu j'ai trouvé une poignée de
rechange dans les vestiaires 1 alors
allons trouver cette peine de rechange
dans des putains de vestiaires non mais
j'en peux plus ça c'est la combi d'un
homme qui tue d'autres gens à montreuil
à quoi ici mais au tome juste nul ça
c'était faible et vous remercie pour ce
n'est pas d'une pile c'est un leurre
putain merde appuyé sur un pour allumer
ton putain briquet
bon bah ça va être les marches gauche
droite haha
s'il ya quelqu'un qu'il se manifeste je
ne rigole points attention j'ai terminé
à l'isolation pour votre gouverne à ce
peut-être les intimider par l'as par là
bas par rapport bien glauque entrouverte
un au revoir et un bordel ya toujours
cette tombola un peu glauque
oh la la cette pièce on je dirais jamais
un je vous le dis je me lève à nous
courir après c'est sûr je le sens il est
arrivé comme ça il se passe un truc
c'est la fin oui merci d'avoir joué on
espère que tu as pris beaucoup de
plaisir supporte notre kickstarter et
partagent nos jus avec tes amis face à
ces faits puis elles m'ont mis la
pression jusqu'au bout pour me dire
merci d'avoir joué l'analyse des salles
ou oui mais voilà les gens c'est à 27,2
sur storeway la fin est un peu brutal de
la cornée putain le gameplay est intense
bordel et encore plus quand on n'a pas
de lampe torche et briquet mais bon vu
qu'on est des projets d'horreur voilà on
est nuls sur tous les jeux on peut au
moins se vanter sur les jeunes horreur
bon on a fini à l'exhumation ou pas ou
pas oui j'espère que ça vous a plu si le
cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude et ça fait plaisir de vous
faire un petit jeu d'horreur qui fait
vraiment extrêmement flipper son centre
en retrait dans une nouvelle vidéo merci
d'avoir gardé kg à tout le monde
pis les marchés lauriers au passage